(Laughter)
It's easy to think so,
especially when we see a few prominent examples
that dominate the conversation.
Well, it turns out, in the long run, they don't.
There's really rich research on this by Morgan McCall and Michael Lombardo
when they were at the Center for Creative Leadership.
They found that the number one reason tied to executive failure
was an insensitive, abrasive or bullying style.
There will always be some outliers that succeed despite their incivility.
Sooner or later, though,
most uncivil people sabotage their success.
For example, with uncivil executives,
it comes back to hurt them when they're in a place of weakness
or they need something.
People won't have their backs.
But what about nice guys?
Does civility pay?
Yes, it does.
And being civil doesn't just mean that you're not a jerk.
Not holding someone down isn't the same as lifting them up.
Being truly civil means doing the small things,
like smiling and saying hello in the hallway,
listening fully when someone's speaking to you.
Now, you can have strong opinions,
disagree, have conflict or give negative feedback civilly,
with respect.
Some people call it "radical candor,"
where you care personally,
but you challenge directly.
So yes, civility pays.
In a biotechnology firm, colleagues and I found
that those that were seen as civil
were twice as likely to be viewed as leaders,
and they performed significantly better.
Why does civility pay?
Because people see you as an important -- and a powerful --
unique combination of two key characteristics:
warm and competent, friendly and smart.
In other words, being civil isn't just about motivating others.
It's about you.
If you're civil, you're more likely to be seen as a leader.
You'll perform better, and you're seen as warm and competent.
But there's an even bigger story about how civility pays,
and it ties to one of the most important questions around leadership:
What do people want most from their leaders?
We took data from over 20,000 employees around the world,
and we found the answer was simple:
respect.
Being treated with respect was more important
than recognition and appreciation,
useful feedback,
even opportunities for learning.
Those that felt respected were healthier,
more focused,
more likely to stay with their organization
and far more engaged.
So where do you start?
How can you lift people up and make people feel respected?
Well, the nice thing is, it doesn't require a huge shift.
Small things can make a big difference.
I found that thanking people,
sharing credit,
listening attentively,
humbly asking questions,
acknowledging others and smiling
has an impact.
Patrick Quinlan, former CEO of Ochsner Health [System],
told me about the effects of their 10-5 way,
where if you're within 10 feet of someone,
you make eye contact and smile,
and if you're within five feet,
you say hello.
He explained that civility spread,
patient satisfaction scores rose,
as did patient referrals.
Civility and respect can be used to boost an organization's performance.
When my friend Doug Conant took over as CEO of Campbell's Soup Company in 2001,
the company's market share had just dropped in half.
Sales were declining,
lots of people had just been laid off.
A Gallup manager said it was the least engaged organization
that they had surveyed.
And as Doug drove up to work his first day,
he noticed that the headquarters was surrounded by barbwire fence.
There were guard towers in the parking lot.
He said it looked like a minimum security prison.
It felt toxic.
Within five years, Doug had turned things around.
And within nine years, they were setting all-time performance records
and racking up awards, including best place to work.
How did he do it?
On day one, Doug told employees
that he was going to have high standards for performance,
but they were going to do it with civility.
He walked the talk, and he expected his leaders to.
For Doug, it all came down to being tough-minded on standards
and tenderhearted with people.
For him, he said it was all about these touch points,
or these daily interactions he had with employees,
whether in the hallway, in the cafeteria or in meetings.
And if he handled each touch point well,
he'd make employees feel valued.
Another way that Doug made employees feel valued
and showed them that he was paying attention
is that he handwrote over 30,000 thank-you notes to employees.
And this set an example for other leaders.
Leaders have about 400 of these touch points a day.
Most don't take long, less than two minutes each.
The key is to be agile and mindful in each of these moments.
Civility lifts people.
We'll get people to give more and function at their best
if we're civil.
Incivility chips away at people and their performance.
It robs people of their potential,
even if they're just working around it.
What I know from my research is that when we have more civil environments,
we're more productive, creative, helpful, happy and healthy.
We can do better.
Each one of us can be more mindful
and can take actions to lift others up around us,
at work, at home, online,
in schools
and in our communities.
In every interaction, think:
Who do you want to be?
Let's put an end to incivility bug
and start spreading civility.
After all, it pays.
Thank you.
(Applause)